maybe it was a different comic that was
out of pocket though that was me you can
edit that out yeah we keep that in but
I'm just saying sh your mouth okay yeah
I thought it was badass that's what's up
D yeah good but let's beautiful pubes by
the way you like my lips I like your
pubes hey I would never show my pubes
off my lips all day every day my pubes
no yeah yeah why you don't like yours
nah you shave it nah so what year did
you start I started like um 20 17 2016
something like that that's when you
started stand up ient yeah but he's also
27 so like that's already like in dog
100 it literally is though but from to
go from that to a Netflix special I just
don't understand how F that's so fast 26
so you've been since you were 19 yeah I
was like 19 I maybe like just turned 19
something like that wow that's like what
menia did I mean I know I don't know if
that's a great great comparison but than
thank you I guess well I mean menia did
his first HB special when he was 20
really that early damn [__] holy [__]
that's really he was young you know what
I mean wow yeah it's he was young dude
so I'm just saying that you know the
trajectory I'm not saying the style or
you know the ethics of it you know have
you met him yeah you I like him nice
yeah he was real nice in in Texas yeah
yeah he's a nice guy yeah he's super
nice yeah yeah did you do shows with him
mhm yeah he's great and then he I also
want to say this and this is going to
make people go crazy but he's a beast on
state is he not yeah I saw yeah I saw
him kill I saw he destroys D yeah like
people don't understand how and and i i
f with every comic people always go you
know I mean yeah but he does yeah but
yeah but yeah yeah but he [__]
murders up there too you know what I
mean you got you got you got to give him
that yeah yeah yeah you know yeah I
agree that's saw him murder every show
yeah so what happened to what about
George George yeah what happened with
George I don't know I guess dude what
trino was talking dude woke up one
morning had some
haterade n he he apologized trino um I
didn't really get what that dude's deal
was maybe I still don't um what' you do
well like they were on George Lopez's
podcast right which for the record I
didn't really care that George was like
mean or whatever say
uh Chino kept like bringing me up he was
like we got to help it's up to us to
like help the Ralph bar bosers of the
world which I didn't really catch it at
first but after that I was like I've
never met that guy I mean I'm still
waiting on the help I
guess will you never met trino no I've
never met him why he talk to you like
he's voice with you yeah that's what I'm
saying that's what started to bug me the
days after cuz on the days after people
were commenting like look man like good
looking now trino is a real one I was
like wait why are they [__]
complimenting him like well he's from
Texas right he lives there I don't I
guess you never ran into trivia I've
been friends with him for almost 20
years 25 years I've seen his stuff but I
never like yeah really never even cross
paths how about cristella Alonzo she's
from Dallas you cross path with her I've
I've seen her but I don't haven't cross
pathed with her I think I I think one
time I saw her perform live I think in
Addison uhhuh I might be getting it
wrong but yeah I've never I've never met
her have you met
anybody I mean can we start there yeah
yeah yeah you have you cross path with
anybody um give me a big name of you
cross the pass once or twice but I try
to I try to walk a road that hasn't been
walked before FR
wizard no but yeah Steve trino was like
you know it's up to us to help Ralph
barosas of the world and George like he
brought up my name quite a few times and
eventually George was like who the [__]
is that guy like [__] that guy don't say
his name like look out for yourself he's
like [__] that guy what's his name
Jeremy barbasa damn wow that would have
been a cool comedy name like I wish I
would have thought of that one first to
be honest um I mean don't get me wrong
George has done our podcast he's a
friend of mine so I'm not going to say
anything in ill will no
but that is a weird no that's a weird
thing to say say but I want to say
something that that's the weird word but
I'll say this I didn't really care what
he said about me cuz feel like you could
have brought up anybody's name and would
have been like [__] whoever you're
saying I think it's like one of those
Heat of the Moment type things he did a
call and apologize which I really
appreciated he did call you yeah oh
that's cool D but I didn't I didn't want
him to apologize I was like no man you
got to do that he's like no no I do I do
whatever um I didn't want him to
apologize cuz I'm like bro it's his
podcast like he paid for the equipment
say what you want like yeah good point
but also can I say this all right it's I
think because of the G the newer
generation is very sensitive
they are yeah I agree as a as a
generation they're a little bit more
sensitive as comedy fans especially as
comedy fans right can call but the
comics are a little sensitive yeah